[Musique]
moncrabeau petite ville du gers serait
aux dires des habitants la capitale
mondiale du mensonge affirmations non
vérifiées si ce n'est par les
réalisateurs de la séquence qui va
suivre
jacques delarue et louis doucet je vais
vous raconter l'histoire d'un chasseur à
l'époque ont chacun plusieurs pistes ont
alors un jour le prologue par au moins
un opérateur sommes pas si vous savez où
c'est pour chasser le lièvre lorsqu'il
fait au bois et qui voulait charger son
pays il avait la poudre mais j'avais
oublié le port comment le faire il voit
de grands reporters il le ramasse
élimination visitant nos talons du fusil
et puis il attend au bout de quelques
instants un énorme lièvre se présente
par neil utile la fumée se dissipe pas
le lièvre l'onu après ils reviennent à
l'affût il revoit ce lièvre caisse et le
lièvre que j'ai tu que j'ai tiré l'an
dernier et il est son camarade qui lui
dit mais comment l'as-tu reconnu qu'il
avait sous la queue un petit chêne
[Applaudissements]
rendez vous demain à 10h30 pour la
délivrance d'un brevet de moniteur sur
la place devant l'hôtel de vérité la
france a des ressources que bien des
français ignorent peut-être n'avez-vous
pas encore remarqué mais moncrabeau
possède l'église tient qu une académie
des menteurs qui n'a pas sa pareille
monsieur lavaur pour koné k2000 des
menteurs est-ce que cela un rapport avec
l'idée que l'on peut se faire rapidement
des gascons oui je crois oui est à se
rappeler l'époque où vivait dans
l'canyon qui était quand même un tableur
et
tekken été inventé et investira vérité
ça vous êtes un conservatoire du
mensonge je le pense et s'il ya une
technique du mensonge
non c'est le mensonge était spontané ça
ne s'apprend pas votre académie et laval
activités qu'il avait autrefois
évidemment et ça se comprend facilement
parce que il y a maintenant la les
journaux la radio la télévision pour
dire qu'ils vous font une concurrence
non mais nous sommes dépassés par ces
gens là
[Musique]
quels sont les rapports de l'église avec
l'académie des menteurs à moncrabeau jeu
contient aucun cas contraire on dit
qu'il faut pas manquer oui c'est
l'évangile c'est l'évangile soit il faut
pas mentir c'est son retour marois
sienne soit pas d'accord on sait
seulement mentir ici à moncrabeau
c'est plutôt braqué comprenez c'est
qu'ils sont devenus amis avaient les
qualités requises pour recevoir le
projet de l'académie des menteurs
nous lui demanderons aujourd'hui nous
allons apporter une preuve bombe écouté
puisque vous insistez vous en raconter
une petite histoire de deux retraités
qui sur l'esplanade du fort regarde
l'abbaye le premier et au second
regarde mon ami lee regard de ces
deux-roues gens sous le pont
l'autre se penchent regarde écoute non à
cette distance je ne les vois pas mais
je les entends au long de l'académie des
menteurs
je vous le décerne pour que vous
puissiez en tout temps et en tout lieu
travestir la vérité dans les montées sur
le siège ou et embrasser la pierre de
vérité qui est situé au dessus de votre
tête
merci
les femmes ont une sérieuse réputation
de menteur menteuse je sais pas si vous
avez observé les élèves du conservatoire
en question sont plutôt des hommes
[Musique]